are you excited for resident evil 7 cap  comments to the developers latest  earnings QA has been posted and the team  has high hopes for the new resident evil  title to the tune of 4 million copies  and beyond the QA stated we're expecting  four million units sales worldwide in  this fiscal year what is more the sales  life cycles for titles has grown due to  digital distribution so we expect this  game to become a foundation title  producing revenue not limited to the  next two fiscal years but into the long  term as well resident evil 7 comes to  ps4 xbox one and pc on january twenty  four twenty seventeen that's just three  days before the latest movie Resident  Evil the final chapter hits theaters on  the 27th keep an eye on gamespot for  more announcements from the studio and  for all the latest Resident Evil news  you're already in the right place  you